regardez ces futurs mariés karine
sénégal tremblay et éric l'orangé devait
se marier le 30 mai mais est ce que le
mariage aura lieu
ils ont payé un gros montant en à
conques et aujourd'hui ils ont peur de
le perdre
parce que l'établissement refuse de les
rembourser pour l'instant ce qui leur
fait dire que l'établissement joue dur
avec eux karine et eric invoque la force
majeure pour résilier le contrat
c'est à dire l'impossibilité pour les
commerçants d'offrir le service à cause
la pandémie mais selon l'établissement
rien ne dit que l'état d'urgence sera
encore en vigueur le 30 mai ça laisse
karine et eric dans l'incertitude totale
et ne savent pas quoi dire alors 140
invités
imaginez alors ils voudraient résilié
tout de suite leurs problèmes s'ils
annulent tout de suite sans savoir si
l'état d'urgence en vigueur le jour de
leur mariage c'est que le commerçant a
beau jeu pour leur dire vous voulez
annulé tout de suite alors en vertu de
votre contrat et de la clause
d'annulation vous perdez votre acompte
alors pour être remboursé le couple doit
attendre que le gouvernement et met un
nouveau décret qui va prolonger l'état
d'urgence jusqu'à la date de leur
mariage
officiellement laissé le code nombreux
futurs mariés par exemple martin et
amélie qui nous ont contactés qui elles
aussi sont stressés parce que leur
cérémonie a eu lieu en juillet vous vous
poser plein de questions à ce sujet vous
aussi toutes les réponses sont sur notre
site internet radio trait d'union
canada.ca barres obliques la facture
cliquez sur le bouton coved 19